the government has published the latest
r number for the uk it's estimated to be
between 0.7
and 0.9 that is a slight change from 0.6
to
0.9 last week let's get some analysis
from skies iva bennett who's in the
newsroom for us look all of the data
certainly this week has been moving in
the right direction how much of a worry
will it be just that the bottom end of
this
our number this estimate is a little bit
up
well i don't think it's too much of a
worry actually this is the first time
this has changed in two weeks as you say
the bottom
estimate has crept up slightly and so
the range has narrowed and we know the r
number can sit anywhere within this
range this week is between 0.7 and 0.9
i say it's not too much of a worry
because the key thing is that it's
overall the r is below one which means
the epidemic
is still shrinking that is the national
picture for the whole of the uk
although it does seem uh to be shrinking
more slowly in some areas compared to
others
i think that if there is one worry to
pick out from all this it's
it's the upper estimate for the
northeast and yorkshire which has crept
up ever so slightly from 0.9
to 1. anything above one of course means
that the virus is spreading again uh
it's just a small change but i say as i
say it's the first kind of wrinkle in
what has been a
a gradually improving picture in all the
data we've got and other data we've had
today also kind of reinforces this
positive trend
the r number is published alongside
what's called the growth rate which
shows that
which kind of refers to the daily change
in infection numbers
and this latest growth we have is
between
minus five percent and minus three
percent so again that shows that
case numbers are still dropping off and
it's worth remembering that the r number
is kind of a general view of the last
few weeks it's not a live snapshot
and what's more this current level of
somewhere between 0.7 and 0.9 is the
same level
as what we had last summer kind of june
july time when we came out of that first
lockdown so
so broadly speaking it's still you know
a positive trend and all of this is
reinforced by separate data we had
earlier today from the office for
national statistics
and their weekly uh infection survey
that showed an estimate of uh for the
week ending february 26th so last
friday in england one in 220
people within the community had covered
19. that's down from 1 in 145 the
previous week so significant decline
and also it's the lowest level since
october the 1st
and in all nations the percentage of
people testing positive decreased in
wales for example
uh it was one in uh 285 testing positive
in northern ireland the ratio is one in
325 and lower still in
scotland where the estimate for uh the
number of people testing positive was
one in
335 now regionally speaking within
england of course there are still
quite considerable variations within the
infection rate similar to what we saw in
the r number statistics so again the
northeast has the highest prevalence of
the virus one in 150 people
the lowest prevalence is in the south
west one in 365 but overall as i say
the trend is still a positive one